anyway yeah you know when I first
started out in business and wanted to
become financially free I used to travel
to Africa India freaking America if
there was a mentor or a program or
something that was going to help me get
to the next step I would just travel
wherever I needed to travel I would pay
what I needed to pay go where I needed
to go and one of the things that really
kind of baffles me and perks me hi Chris
is when people say Sammy well I know
that you're a multi multi-millionaire
that runs the property investors crash
course which is a two day program and oh
my goodness I know there's a free
promotion I went out I can book on for
free no catches but you know what it's a
little far from my house I think I'll
wait for you to come in my neighborhood
and run a crash course by there's
nothing more irritating for me I'm
actually like I don't angry or or
offended when people say that but here's
the thing in a three-hour konzern II
will stop you getting equipped to become
financially free then you are so
stoppable like the very very first
hurdle that there is to the journey
before you've even been trained up
you're stopped but like a 2 or 3 hour
car or even six hour car journey when
there's other people come to the crash
course from all over the world if that
people come from Australia like I don't
know if I didn't want people like that
at the crash course because you okay
okay what's gonna happen your way into
the crash course comes in your hometown
then a quest force will come to your
hometown it probably will never happen
but let's say it does imagine if I had a
bunch of losers at the crash course
still were only there because it
happened to be on their doorstep you
know what would happen the percentage of
success students at that crash course
would be very very low so the more it
stings you have to travel it shows that
you're unstoppable
and if you're unstoppable to the first
hurdle you'll be unstoppable with the
next few hurdles so yeah that's just one
thing that really really kind of chooses
me off personally because I just can't
imagine myself saying that I just can't
imagine be sank on a two day program or
it's four hours in the car so I'm not
going to go there's a reason that we
have cars you know I mean geez was like
a hundred years ago and we'd have to go
horseback just to better car let's do a
freaking audio CD while you're in the
car clearly decent education I'm done